you're you're making the assumption that
that men are slaughtering women and
that's just not the case and even if
you're gonna you're gonna talk about me
what did I do what do you mean
because you're saying you're part of the
problem
because who's who's who's who's gonna be
the ones to end racism black people or
white people it'd be like me sitting
there saying to you if you tell your
sons okay okay but but otherwise they
ain't gonna get they ain't gonna get
racially abused you tell you it's on
your end that's what it's like but if I
if I'm not racist how am I part of the
problem because you've benefited no I
understand what you're saying and I
agree like like if anything like I I
have a whole team in Nigeria that works
for me